muy buenos días pues así es fue un
fenómeno momentos unos minutos muy
emocionantes aquí llenos de aplausos una
vez que el falcon 9 pues logró despegar
desde cabo cañaveral hubo aplausos allí
y luego hubo más aplausos todavía cuando
ya logró su dragón entrar estar cuando
falcon 9 puso a cruz dragón ya en órbita
unos 200 kilómetros la distancia de la
tierra a unos 27.000 kilómetros por hora
en esa velocidad y cuando los cuerpos de
los astronautas pues eran sometidos a
una fuerza g de 14 es decir 4 veces el
peso del cuerpo en cada uno de ellos
ahora pues el criterium va hacia la
estación espacial internacional pero se
va a demorar prácticamente unas 24 horas
18 24 horas en llegar hasta allí y
hablamos aquí con el club the new reyes
astronauta francesa de la agencia
europea y estuvo a bordo de la estación
espacial en el 2001 nos dijo cómo va a
desarrollarse estas estas horas antes de
la llegada a la plataforma espacial
los diez minutos de decolaje y puesta en
órbita son intensos de suma vigilancia y
luego tienen tiempo de relajarse un poco
en la cápsula
jibril a la estación en esta parte del
viaje que los llevará a la estación
espacial para estar en forma y llegar
bien a la estación donde se juzga cómo
podrán tomar una siesta una vez estén en
órbita y hayan hecho las comprobaciones
esto les permitirá adaptarse a la
microgravedad dijo white
bueno lo cierto es que durante todo este
tiempo
dragón va a darle la vuelta a la tierra
16 veces esto le va a permitir a ganar
un poco en velocidad también en
encenderán los motores unas 4 a 5 veces
durante este espacio de tiempo y bueno
ya después logrará pues llegar a la
estación espacial internacional y que
comience finalmente esa misión de seis
meses de club
2 hay que saber algo y es que como bien
lo decía la enviada especial a cabo
cañaveral pues van a estar todos estos
astronautas 11 astronautas a conviviendo
unos días y luego ya serán siete por
espacio de los próximos seis meses le
preguntamos también al señor ay qué es
lo más difícil de estas misiones largas
y esto fue lo que nos contó cómo te
presentamos cuando la misión ya hay
momentos muy intensos tienen un programa
científico muy cargado un software son
cientos de científicos y de ingenieros
en tierra les han encomendado tareas
mantener esta estación que ya tiene 20
años en órbita y habrá que hacer salidas
extra
para cambiar paneles solares que proveen
energía y hay que cambiarlos porque ya
tienen unos años
bueno y pues el compa finalmente es casi
como ir en taxi hasta la estación
espacial internacional porque todo está
automatizado y una vez logre este
acoplamiento se espera eso sea en la
mañana de este sábado hay que saber como
bien lo decían si es una misión muy
importante muy importante sobre todo
para para la agencia espacial europea
porque bueno estoy pisando un fuerte que
regresa digamos o que hace este este
asocio con a la nasa con jaxa igualmente
pero también porque es una misión a
clave para esta agencia sobre todo como
parte del programa artemisa que busca
poner de nuevo a los hombres al hombre
sobre la luna esto entre 2024 y 2025